foreign
we are live on the electronic computer
machine I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report and welcome to another
Friday Roundtable Extravaganza we've got
two rookies with me today that's right
two new voices for you joining me today
is a British author and journalist Peter
Lloyd and a reporter for Turning Point
USA and a writer for the post-millennial
Savannah Hernandez Peter and Savannah
welcome to the Reuben report
thank you for having us
in the room considering you're both
supposed to be racist in America
well I have no doubt that even across
the pond you guys are all racist too and
that's going to be what we're going to
figure out today but uh actually that's
a good place to start because Savannah
we played a video of yours earlier in
the week you went viral on the internet
because you were out what what
university was this at was that UC Davis
UT Austin in the Heart of Texas Saturday
that makes it even worse you're in Texas
although Austin is a little bit of an
odd situation in Texas uh and I want to
play a portion of this video because
basically you go out there you talk to
kids about their privilege and some of
the things that they seem to be confused
about and lady you were Doling out red
pills it was absolutely beautiful take a
look I I grew up as a white man and you
you're the exact opposite you know and
so it's like my experiences are going to
be different from yours how come I think
uh you know there's a thing of like
white privilege uh what privileges do
you have that I don't have oh see that's
the question I keep asking myself
because like in this day and age like
all the laws I say all the laws you know
I'm
it's hard to speak on something I'm not
fully knowledgeable of so like I'm sorry
if I like make a mistake in saying this
but it's like
like uh
would you think it's a problem in
society when white people think that
they have more privileges than brown or
black people
yeah and I think that's sort of the
agenda that's pushed off because
personally it's like not that I think
I'm more privileged than anyone else
because I had to work to get where I was
and that's like why do you have that
mentality immediately where you you know
kind of apologize to me like let's talk
about privilege let's talk about I'm a
white man in America so we could have
grown up differently why is that your
first initial reaction to me as a brown
woman
you're getting me good see this is the
kind of conversations that I love having
um and I think it comes from a place of
like
uh I wouldn't say caution but like in
this day and age people are so quick to
judge and react and cancel and so I
guess it's that that like caution to go
into an interview like this I'm like I
don't know where we're at but now I know
where we're at and I can like uh go for
real
Savannah you are young you undoubtedly
have a long illustrious career ahead of
you but like it might not get better
than that it is so perfect what you did
there your response the way you asked
the questions and the way that he
actually went with you along that ride I
mean are you finding that basically all
of these kids at these schools when you
go just don't know and if you can pull
that initial thread that the rest
happens pretty organically
absolutely I mean we can even reverse
the roles I've talked to minority
students who've talked to me about white
privilege and all of the Privileges that
white men are awarded to to the to them
that you know are not given to us
minority women or just minority people
in gen in general and when you reverse
it I get the exact same response where
it's just like a long pause of silence
and these students are like well I can't
explain to you what privileges white men
have but I know that they have them and
I have to go now and then they end up
running away from me so you know whether
it's a white student that I'm
interviewing or a minority student
nobody knows what privileges are awarded
but this is a continuous talking point
and I'm just absolutely tired of it
which is why I finally pushed back and
we weren't even talking about white
privilege I was talking to students
about trans women and international
women's day but of course because I am
Brown when I do talk to White students
White Privilege is something that
consistently comes up and I'm absolutely
tired of it so you know I always take
the opportunity to help these students
critically think because our entire
education system teaches them to do the
exact opposite of that and again I still
haven't got an answer as to what
privileges a Dave Rubin or Peter Lloyd
have that I do not especially in the
United States of America Peter Peter
speaking of white privilege your white
and you're British that's like as white
as it possibly gets short of you eating
white bread while you were on this show
right now what do you make of all of
these kids who have been brainwashed
like that kid he obviously he was a
thoughtful person and I don't even want
the video to go viral to make fun of him
because he he did the right thing right
he was confronted with truth and
hopefully he evolved which is what you
want from everybody but what is it about
all of these kids this generation that
has led them to this place of of
unearned guilt
well I mean I think you're absolutely
right and he was very graceful in how he
acted with that interview and I was
actually I was quite full of admiration
for him really because even though what
he was spouting was complete nonsense um
it wasn't really his fault because he's
symptomatic of the system which has
actively been brainwashing people for
decades I mean it's known as the Long
March through the institutions
Academia was taken over many many
decades ago and this is the result this
young man who is on this video is
absolutely representative of how
successful this March through the
institutions has been these people who
are often very intelligent they no
longer think critically they just recite
the woke Mantra and that's so evident
because as soon as Savannah pushed why
why do you believe that what privileges
do you have that I don't he couldn't
answer them
yeah it's just so beautiful when you
confront them and then they fold you
know quicker than a wet paper bag and
then hopefully
go ahead right I have to say like you
know a round of applause for that video
because that was a a glorious glorious
moment and I have to say it it
reaffirmed my my glimmer of faith in
journalism
well it's a nice way to kick off the
show because we're going to be focusing
on why this woke ideology and diversity
Equity inclusion and all of this
unearned guilt it's not just bad because
of what it's doing to college kids but
it's leaking out into society and quite
literally causing Banks to to melt down
so the big story of course this week uh
with Silicon Valley Bank going down and
thus being bailed out by the government
but now we're finding out that there's
all sorts of bad stuff attached to this
thing uh here's a tweet from the
post-millennial you guys know how I feel
about that guy uh Gavin Newsom praised
Biden's bailout of svb uh but omitted
the fact that his wine companies and his
personal accounts all use Silicon Valley
Bank we've got a little bit more from
the daily wire Newsome praised the Biden
Administration on Sunday after the
federal government announced that the
Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation
FDIC would cover all the depositor
losses from the Silicon Valley Bank
collapse the bailout was a surprise for
svb's largest depositors as FDIC
insurance is guaranteed to cover only
two hundred fifty thousand dollars per
account Newsome said that the fdic's
decision would have profoundly would
have profoundly positive impacts on
California businesses but he failed to
mention that his own wineries May stand
to benefit from the fdic's unusual
action according to the intercept Newsom
owned wineries Cade Odette and plumpjack
all banked with svb and each was at risk
of losing its deposit if it held over
the two hundred fifty thousand dollar
threshold in a single account Newsome
also kept personal accounts at the
failed Bank A source told The Intercept
Governor newsom's business and financial
Holdings are held and managed by a blind
trust as they have been since he was
first elected in 2018 a Newsome
spokesman told the intercept and in an
email I mean Savannah this should not
surprise us at all right I mean first
off that he would you know he's got
millions and millions of dollars
invested in these wineries he personally
is worth I think probably around 20
million can we try to get a number on
that
um but that he was lobbying for the
government to bail out his bank it just
shouldn't surprise us right like there's
nothing that should surprise us you know
nothing that Gavin Newsom does surprises
me he is one of the most corrupt
politicians that we have I I love to
remember the days during covid when he
kept his entire State locked down and
forced everyone to wear a face mask
while he was whining and dining with his
friends while stopping people from you
know going and visiting their loved ones
in the hospital so he's kept that same
energy throughout the years where it's
like oh I'm gonna be saved I'm gonna
live my life and I'm gonna get the
bailouts and do whatever I want good
luck to everybody else by the way you're
going to pay for my bad policies and the
bad policies that my party pushes
um going to svb I believe they also
donated 73 million or some crazy number
like that to Black lives matter and
other social programs and again we have
to ask the question who is paying for
these bailouts that's right us the
American taxpayers it's an absolute joke
this Administration has run this entire
country into the ground and this is a
direct result of diversity equity and
inclusion it's an absolute joke and you
can look at the diversity hires that are
currently in the White House like like
Pete bootage and Kamala Harris Pete by
the way I confronted in East Palestine
for his horrific response to the people
of Ohio who were impacted by that toxic
trained derailment why is it that we
have such slow response from this
government why is it that when Joe Biden
comes out and says the banking system is
safe we all automatically know in fact
that the banking system is not safe this
is again this Administration is a joke
and
as a minority woman I don't even like
that label but that's the one Society
tries to push on me I reject this okay
the the Dei nonsense because look at
what just happened at Stanford as well
the other day who had the diversity
equity and inclusion officer of Stanford
pushing back against the first amendment
in constitutional rights at a law school
so again too I know I just gave a broad
range of examples but understand just
how much this is infiltrated every
single aspect of our society and we the
American people are dealing with the
direct consequence of that yeah well
said and that's exactly why I set up the
show the way we did this week because I
think still for whatever reason a lot of
people still think oh no it's just
happening on college campuses and a
weird a weird selection of purple-haired
kids will get out into the real world
and things will be different but Peter I
don't know if you saw this but at svb
bank they had a diversity Equity
inclusion Department of many many people
and they were focused on those programs
they only had a chief risk officer for
about three months and then you wonder
why is it that they were investing in
all of these highly risky companies and
the bankrupt and the company basically
went bankrupt shocking right right right
I I'm not risk manager she was busy off
creating a lesbian visibility day and
something to do with black lives matter
I mean you know because the very first
thing I think of when I go into a Banks
and deposit money is you know how
diverse is it here how many black
disabled lesbians are buying behind the
desk and you know what are you doing to
Mark certain days of the year it's so
ludicrous and quite frankly the bank
deserved to collapse there should have
been no federal intervention at all
um not least because
it's going to benefit a very very small
minority of Californians under Garvin
Nissan's power so it should have been
allowed to just collapse and go away but
you know maybe
I don't know I I for one was completely
surprised that Gavin Youth and did uh
did this because it was like you know
okay he was the guy who died at French
Laundry without the mask while mundating
everyone else and okay he was the guy
who had the affair with his AIDS wife
and okay he's a pathological liar but we
should really believe him now because he
was just acting in the best interests of
Californians yeah yeah sure sure well is
it isn't that Democrat privilege more
than anything else right we always talk
about privilege in this country I keep
arguing there's one privilege it's
Democrat privilege you can ruin
everything you can wreck every
institution you're part of you can do
all of the wrong things and just as in
Gavin Newsome case you will get go from
mayor to governor and the guy's got his
eyes on the White House obviously
Savannah
exactly exactly uh you know this is
something that I've seen in my own
career as a journalist right I have
worked as hard as I can to go out on the
street cover these stories and just tell
the American people the truth and as a
direct result of that I was censored by
Twitter I was silenced and I was written
off as a fascist nazi by left-wing
progressives meanwhile all of the people
on the left like the CNN and MSNBC
pundits who continue to lie to the
American people are propped up by
Society are told that you know we're all
told that they are the Arbiters of truth
that everything that they see is
incredible and amazing so we see this
this same pattern right whether it's in
politics media Corporate America the
more left liberal and Progressive you
are the higher up your trajectory is for
your career but again our entire Society
is facing the direct consequence of that
because we have people who have no
ability to be in the positions that they
are leading our country right now it's
why we have a sitting Senator that is
currently hospitalized right now where
is John fetterman why is it that it's
now okay for politicians who clearly are
you know mentally or physically not
healthy enough to actually hold their
positions in leadership positions why
how did we get to this point and
nobody's asking about fetterman which is
incredible it's like literally nobody's
asking which reminds me remember a
couple months ago when Joe Biden out of
nowhere said that he had cancer and then
everyone was like no no it's not that he
has cancer it's that he has dementia
it's like we ask so little of these
people uh Peter quick before we move on
Savannah how long were you banned for
because you were you had a long band on
Twitter how long was that for you two
years wow you should have stayed off to
be quite Frank but Peter you were all so
bad you were banned for how long
yourself yeah I was in the gulag for 18
months 18 months two years I gotta tell
you guys you probably were happier quite
frankly
no probably
um just just one quick thing Dave before
we move on talking about the Democrat
privilege it's so evident in how the
media have reacted to this Revelation
because if you look at
LA Times San Francisco Chronicles New
York Times none of them have even
touched on
um you know his nuisance conflict of
interest here with the wineries they've
all completely ignored it and you have
loads of people on Twitter who are
already leaping through his defense If
This Were the santis and this was a
story based in Florida
you can bunk on the fact that there
would be outrage and yeah pun intended
there but it's true I mean the contrast
in how these people would be treated is
massive and it just proves Democrat
privilege right I mean do you think that
even if it wasn't DeSantis let's say it
was Trump Jr so not even Trump himself
but if Trump Jr had money in a winery uh
and then Trump lobbied for the bank to
get the ballot you think that perhaps
we'd be in a slightly different
situation uh one final thought on this
we checked the numbers uh Gavin's worth
a cool 22 million so he did have a bunch
to lose and his reign of terror will
continue but let's keep going with uh
California because man it is insane in
California they're going for reparations
in San Francisco we've got some info
here from NBC payments of five million
dollars to every eligible black adult
the elimination of personal debt and tax
burdens guaranteed annual incomes of at
least ninety seven thousand dollars for
205 50 years and homes in San Francisco
for just one dollar these were some of
the more than 100 recommendations made
by a city appointed reparations
committee tasked with the thorny
question of how to atone for centuries
of slavery and systemic racism and the
San Francisco Board of Supervisors
hearing the report for the first time
Tuesday voiced enthusiastic support for
the ideas listed with some saying money
should not stop the city from doing the
right thing
the draft reparations plan released in
December is unmatched Nationwide in its
specificity and breadth the committee
hasn't done an analysis of the cost of
the proposals but critics have slammed
the plan as financially and politically
impossible an estimate from Stanford
University's Hoover institution which
leans conservative has said it would
cost each non-black family in the city
at least 600
thousand dollars Peter I know you live
in another country thousands of miles
away from San Francisco but how much
will you personally put in you'll chip
in a little something so that uh a young
black man in San Francisco can get ahead
in the world I assume yeah no no I won't
I'll stiff him I'm afraid you know I'll
I'll just point to the Barbary slave
trade and say well hey you know millions
of what Europeans were captured and used
as slaves all across North Africa
between the 16th and 18th century so
let's just call it quits with the whole
reparations thing I mean it's it's
laughable your representatives in
California must be cooking and smoking
meth because it's absolutely crazy over
there I mean I I was looking at it
before and I was thinking if this
actually goes ahead and given that it's
California it might do the state is
going to be on an ex on an Express train
to becoming America's first failed days
and I don't say that lightly there's
already a 22 billion dollar deficit you
know nuisance of the charts
um
people are leaving in droves the
Tactical Sky High if you're going to
start forcing
non-black families to pay out six
hundred thousand dollars or whatever the
Hoover Institute suggested it's gonna
absolutely bankrupt the states and then
that will in turn affect the rest of
Western Civilization it's absurd slavery
was terrible we will we all acknowledge
that we all appreciate it was wrong it
ended white people ended slavery and you
know like I said before it was the
Barbary slave trade white people were
also victims of slavery so if you're
going to have reparations where do you
draw the line why do we stop at black
people let's go back to the very
beginning of the supply chain because it
wasn't white people Gathering of black
people and putting them in cages it was
African kings and it was the African
Elite they were selling their own people
so if you really want to get reparations
let's go right back to the source and
get it from them
Savannah isn't it also just a
misunderstanding of human nature like
the idea that you can give people
something because of something that
didn't happen to them it maybe happened
to their ancestors maybe and also
because they don't believe in IDs in
California how are we going to prove any
of this but the idea that you could hand
them a certain amount of money and then
psychologically they'd be like
okay we're good to go thanks won't need
anything else really appreciate it it
just doesn't it doesn't pass a basic
psych 101 snuff test absolutely and a
couple of points that I want to make
here there was never slavery in
California why are we forcing people who
never owned slaves to pay reparation to
people who have never been slaves that
makes zero sense also go walk the
streets of San Francisco I've done it
Dave you've done it Peter if you haven't
done it don't do it you know what you're
gonna see you're gonna keep the smoke
and Fentanyl you're gonna see people
defecating industry you're going to see
children walking past tense cities where
there are open drug deals okay I have
walked through San Francisco I've
reported on their drug and homeless
crisis and I promise you that there are
so many other things that the city of
San Francisco can be investing in like
making their city streets safe but what
do they continue to do they continue to
invest funding that they do not have
because you know the government does
this great thing where they think that
you can just print money and keep
printing it out and then you know give
it out you can get 5 million there 5
million here and uh that's just how
money Works absolutely not again this
falls on the American taxpayer so just
like that article stated this is not
even financially feasible and to the
point of giving you know a black
American five million dollars our
education system does not even teach
Americans how to properly handle money
so guess what you can get five million
dollars to somebody and if that person
has no idea how to use money guess what
they're going to be broke in another
couple years I think that's the reality
of it our education system doesn't teach
young Americans how taxes work how
credit Works how money Works in any way
shape or form so you truly can take
somebody in poverty give them a million
dollars and a couple years later they
could very well be poor again because
money is a tool that we do not teach the
American individual how to use for the
record here in the Free State of Florida
we are teaching financial literacy right
now to Santa
so it's a little bit a little bit
different here in Florida than it is in
Cali Peter good
I was just going to say let's also not
pretend that this that this policy won't
be abused because it will do if this is
brought in you're going to have a lot of
Rachel dolls in the future moving to
California actually you're going to have
a lot of people pretending to be black
in the hope of getting five million
dollars I mean hell I'd like five
million dollars
right Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Kimmel might go
back in blackface just to see what kind
of candy you could get
right Jimmy did it Justin Trudeau did
blackface I mean they got away with that
maybe you know the rest of us could
focus and change it also well I do want
to correct your terminology really
quickly here though um because you said
pretending to be black please they're
identifying as black because you can
identify as whatever you want now in the
modern day okay thank you I know Media
Matters watches the show every day and
they're just waiting for one of us to
say something wrong it's just incredible
also just one other thing on this I mean
the the resentment that it would cause
even if you believed it could work even
if the money was there all of that stuff
the resentment that it would cause the
average white or Asian person say Or
Hispanic person living in San Francisco
when their neighbor suddenly is driving
a Bentley and living in a sick house on
the top of the hill and it's because of
the money they put in they're actually
going to create racism so it's just it's
just endless but speaking of endless uh
it's not just California in Minnesota
this is just my God if you have a frying
pan hit yourself in the head right now
uh Minnesota lieutenant governor Peggy
Flanagan listened to her defending sex
changes for minors
because let's be clear clear
this is life affirming and life-saving
health care
when our children tell us who they are
it is our job as grown-ups to listen and
to believe them
that's what it means to be a good parent
you know that Meme from Billy Madison
everything that oh you got a frying pan
I don't know how you got to the kitchen
that quickly the size of a flat in
London these days I'll tell you
um everything she said there was
complete insane it's not affirming care
to chop someone's genitals off Peter
you've talked an awful lot about this go
ahead
yeah it's staggering and what's really
worrying is that this debate just
doesn't seem to be making any Headway I
mean how can anybody justify allowing
miners whose frontal lobes aren't even
fully formed yet to make life-changing
decisions about their bodies it's
absolutely astonishing and it it's proof
that mission creep can become really
really dangerous you know we're now at
the point where we're allowing miners to
make horrendous decisions without giving
them the information that they truly
need Studies have shown that most people
who identify as trans when they're
teenagers are actually just gay and they
grow out of that phase and they they are
so thankful that they didn't have any
surgery
um why would we be encouraging given
that data why would we be encouraging
people to do the opposite to indulge in
something that they don't really know
anything about it's it's staggering and
it's a dereliction of Duties really I
think but for anybody who's who's got
children or young people in their lives
yeah Savannah the line where she says
that children tell us who they are and
it's our job in effect to support them
you guys know I have seven month old and
a five-month-old downstairs my job is to
protect them from the people that would
do them harm and the protect and to
protect them from the confusions of the
world and all of those things not when
they're five years old and tell me that
they're a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle to
to go and buy them a shell or something
or that wasn't the greatest reference
ever but you got the point it's just
they just get everything backwards right
absolutely and I mean even I'm not sure
if this story was true or not but you
can use the example of okay let's say a
child identifies as a cat do we then put
a litter box in the bathroom for them no
we do not we tell that child hey it's
fun to play pretend but you're actually
a little boy or a little girl children
are very vulnerable right that's why we
have laws in place to protect children
that is why we have to teach children
about certain things and that is why our
education system right now is being I
guess overtaken by the lgbtq community
because they do want to teach children
these things when they're very young so
it can become a normalized thing for
them and you know a question that I do
want to go on on the street and start
asking older individuals is hey when you
went to school in the 80s and 90s was
transgenderism this rampant were their
trans children were there this many
trans kids in high school even because
this really does seem like a very recent
phenomenon that is a direct result of
our education system that has been in
full traded so no as a parent it is not
your job to listen to your child and
just believe whatever they say if your
child says oh I love this adult I think
that he's great I want to go marry him
or would you let your child do that no
absolutely not so why are you gonna go
let your child have a life-altering
surgery gender mutilation or gender
mutilation where they could potentially
become infertile for the rest of their
life we need to protect children and the
fact that as a society we cannot come
together and agree on this very simple
topic is it's really devastating on us
well and also by the way Savannah what
you're saying is not just anecdotal
Abigail schreier wrote an absolutely
spectacular book called irreversible
damage where she goes into the data
about how this is a social contagion of
modern times especially when it comes to
young girls uh you know quote-unquote
transitioning to boys but since we're
already honest I've been wanting to play
this clip for a long time when I was
young I wanted to be sound wave sound
wave was a Decepticon he was a
Transformer not a transsexual I wanted
to be sound wave and we found the sound
wave clip for you so this is gratuitous
for me but enjoy
where as Megatron has how shall we say
departed I nominate myself as the new
leader great The Constructor cons form
Devastator the most powerful robot we
shall rule sound wave Superior
Constructor God's inferior who are you
calling inferior nobody would follow an
uncharismatic boar like you
wave uncrismatic
nobody calls Soundwave uncrasmatic Peter
if my parents if I had said to my
parents I want to be Soundwave and they
chop my arm off and put a piece of an
old cassette player that would have been
abuse wouldn't have been
right I have I have an interesting
anecdotal story actually because when I
was younger my best friend at the time
was gay and I remember him saying to me
right we were only about eight years old
and he knew he was gay even at that age
and he said to be right
um I realized what I'm going to do is
when I I'll probably live to 18 so when
I get to 40 I'm gonna live the first
half of my life as a man and I'm gonna
have a sex change and then I'm gonna
live the second half of my life as a
woman wow and then that's how I'm gonna
that's how I'm gonna deal with my life
and he was quite serious about it he was
my eight year old
um and it was only late drawn when he
became an adult and we were talking
about it in the pub and he said I am so
thankful that I didn't have access to
that power to change my body in that way
because I would have been devastated I
know easy that I love being a man I
would not want to be a woman I'm simply
a gay man and I'm really pleased I
didn't make such a big Choice even
though I really felt the age and I felt
like I was correct when I was a
Youngster and that really struck me as
as Illuminating for a lot of young
people in this situation because that is
essentially the truth that that is the
common story that happens with most of
these people but they're not around
they're just gay yeah and as Jordan
Peterson often talks about even if you
fully acknowledge that the the mental
state of a trans person that they you
know that some percentage of people
genuinely 100 believe they are in the
wrong body the idea that you can alter
your body and somehow your problems are
going to go away on the other side after
all of the money and all of the
surgeries and all of the hormone therapy
and all of those things that you're
going to look exactly the way you want
to look and be able to find the partner
who you know is just right for you and
all those things it's probably a pipe
dream in and of itself but there are
some sane voices on this there was a
tweet by Elon Musk that I thought was
quite this was in response to the video
of the Minnesota attorney general that
video that we showed you uh he wrote not
when they're uh fed propaganda by adults
moreover every child goes through an
identity crisis before their personality
slash identity crystallizes therefore we
should allow severe irreversible surgery
or sterilizing drugs that they may
regret until at least the age of 18. so
Savannah that's at least somewhat
refreshing right we do have some voices
pushing back against this stuff although
as Peter said it seems like it just
keeps going and going and going
absolutely it is very refreshing to see
this and I'm glad that we have the
ability to share the truth on Twitter
again thank you Elon Musk for that
because now I am starting to see more
and more posts photos and videos of what
transition surgery really does look like
for young men and young women and it's
not a pretty thing at all if you look at
a double mastectomy and you look at a
young girl who recently had her breasts
chopped off it it looks very horrific it
looks like something we should not be
advocating for in society at all it
looks like the work of a mad scientist
if you will and again too I when I was
younger I didn't want to have kids I was
like ew being a mom that sounds horrible
should I have this have had the decision
when I was 16 years old to go get my
entire uterus taken out because when I
was a teenager I did it maybe want to
have kids now I want to have children
and just like Peter talked about with
his friend when he was younger he he had
this thought process he went through
this phase and as an adult because if
I'm correct I believe your brain isn't
fully developed until you're about about
25 years old when your brain fully
develops and then you realize what you
actually want in life you're very
grateful that you weren't able to make
these life-altering decisions so again
it's so horrific to me that not only can
children go and get these gender
quote-unquote reaffirming surgeries but
on top of that we now have parents that
are capitalizing on their child on their
children's confusion and putting them up
on Tick Tock and platforming little boys
in makeup and dresses and having them
repeat this propaganda that they have
been taught by their parents
I know that that in some ways is the
sickest part of this when you see the
parents putting these videos of the kids
up there you know little boys dressed as
girls and the parents are clearly doing
it again partly because of the social
contagion element it's just to get likes
and retweets and the rest of it but
let's continue because the theme of this
whole week and I guess maybe this whole
year and perhaps the rest of our lives
will be that there are just a series of
Liars who lie about absolutely
everything most of them are in the
mainstream Media or work at our
institutions and uh Joe Scarborough over
at the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC he had fauci on and fauci
I I keep saying it I cannot believe this
guy has not just disappeared like dude
you were the highest paid guy in the
federal government you're getting the
highest pension of anyone in the
government
even if you think you did a good job
just go away for a while but he can't
stop he's addicted to the media and uh
here is fauci on Joe Scarborough
yesterday right and and it's ever
evolving and evolving very quickly it's
just like vaccines people will still go
ah you you got covered even though you
got a vaccine what we didn't we didn't
know none of us knew you didn't know
exactly how those vaccines would impact
the virus
um but we've learned quite a few things
about the vaccines too there's a very
resilient virus it's a very durable
virus and and it morphs very quickly so
so develop a vaccine and it still helps
in a positive way but it doesn't wipe
out coven can you explain what we've
learned about vaccines over the last two
years hmm
well there's one very very obvious fact
that is born up by very solid data Joe
we know that if you compare
unvaccinated people with vaccinated
people with regard to hospitalizations
and death there is a overwhelming and
dramatic difference of a greater
likelihood of hospitalization and death
among the unvaccinated and as the months
went by if you compare vaccinated but
not up to date with boosters with people
who are totally up to date on boosters
there's still a difference in the sense
of vaccinated and updated boosted people
do much better with regard to severity
of disease that's an open and shut case
there's no doubt about that that
actually there is a lot of doubt about
that there are no studies that prove
what he just said right there he keeps
saying it over and over and this is what
every celebrity and every politician
kept saying when they would get covet
after they got vacced and boosted I'm
just so happy I got back to the boosted
because I have lesser coven there are no
studies on that and Robert Malone who's
the inventor and owns more patents on
mRNA technology than anyone he believes
that that the vaccines are actually
degrading people's immune systems which
is why we're getting this Resurgence in
shingles and a whole bunch of other
usually dormant diseases that a lot of
people have so he made that up he
noticed he doesn't reference the study
he doesn't tell you any of the numbers
but he keeps showing up Savannah he just
keeps showing up and we should just
expect he's just gonna keep showing up
Dr fauci is one of the biggest criminals
that I've ever seen in my life and the
fact that he's not in jail right now is
horrific because to be quite honest with
you the way that he handled uh
information to the American people over
the past two years was horrific and
again he really did put so many people's
lives at risk by stopping preventative
treatments because he wanted to wait for
the vaccine and again too you can go
look at the FDA fact sheet that was
updated for the modernity vaccine that
says that myocarditis and pericarditis
are indeed a side effect of this
vaccination for some reason we're barely
Hearing in the media that hey heart
effects are an issue you can go look at
countries that have the highest
vaccination rate like Australia or New
Zealand and you can see that they're
having an unusual uptick in deaths for
some reason and we can't just we can't
put our finger on why that is we've had
so many doctors come forward and speak
out against Dr fauci and what happened
they were silenced and they were
censored they were nine new billionaires
that were created via the covid pandemic
in the big Pharma industry so it is very
clear to see who profited off of this
product it was not the American people
who benefited from it if anything were
facing the consequence and you know I do
a lot of Street work and I like talking
to my fellow Americans and one of the
things that I have heard the most is the
side effects of this vaccination is
people regretting getting this
vaccination people upset that the
government never talked about natural
immunity the government never talked
about going to the gym in fact they shut
gyms down they said hey if you're obese
don't worry about it you're not more at
risk for covid when in fact it was over
70 percent of the people that were
hospitalized and put on ventilators were
morbidly obese so if our government
actually cared about our health they
would be talking about supplements going
out in the sun going and working out
preventative treatments that we could
have uh you know taken for covid-19
before the vaccine was even available
and they gave none of that to the people
because they don't actually care about
our health news flush there for the
audience
thank you for the news flash yeah quite
literally vitamin D it now turns out is
one of the biggest benefit beneficial
things that you can do if you have covet
or before you get covid and they
literally were locking us in our houses
Peter I know a lot of this stuff is
anecdotal but but I think if we don't
talk about the anecdotal stuff we end up
only listening to the quote unquote
experts I was at a party a family party
in New York about two months ago every
single person there was vaxed every
single person except me
virtually everyone got coveted except
for me should I be studied by Anthony
fauci as some sort of superhero and they
should take my blood and replicate it
across the world
absolutely I think maybe you all about
superhero you wanted to be when you were
a boy maybe that has happened
um but yeah unfortunately unfortunately
fancy is not going anywhere he's going
to be around for a very long time and I
think that is why it's so important that
we continue to have these kind of
conversations on on this show and on
similar shows
um you only have to look back a few
months it wasn't so long ago that some
of the world's most eminent doctors were
being censored and banned on Twitter the
Public Town Square for questioning the
vaccines that wasn't so long ago it's
almost within reach so we can't make
fancy go away but now with Elon at the
head of prison we at least have a space
to have a more balanced dialogue and
that's important because that
information can get out to people and
give them more freedom of choice yeah
and piggybacking off that the other
thing you can do is you can move to a
state that is going to protect your
ability to make medical decisions for
yourself we used to have something there
was a whole movement and not that old I
remember a whole movement my body my
choice until they wanted to stick you
with things endlessly but right here in
the Free State of Florida yeah we're
going to keep protecting people and not
force anyone to do anything uh here is
Governor Ron DeSantis talking a bit
about that how many of these Jabs are
you going to take you know you the
traditional vaccine you know you take
you take a shot there may be sometimes
there'd be booster but we wouldn't be
taking them every six months I mean this
is a very new thing
um and it's just it got to the point
where to kind of cover up the lack of
efficacy they would do things like
someone with these politicians they
would they would do do the Jabs then
they'd get covered you know three months
later and they would like tweet out I
have just been diagnosed with covid-19 I
am so thankful that I am vaccinated
against Coke and I'm just thinking to
myself you know if you took the measles
vaccine and then got measles the next
year you would be upset that it didn't
work you wouldn't be thanking the MMR
shot so it's just it's just incredible
Peter one of the things I always talk
about on the show is that when you hear
someone telling the truth it's just
refreshing like you feel better because
I think the truth is so it is such a an
integral piece to humanity that you know
it literally as a physiological effect
on you and that's what I feel when I'm
listening to someone tell the truth
versus fouchy you're sitting there like
you just feel this well now I feel
really a hatred towards him at this
point but the truth it will set us free
will it not
right absolutely and there is something
primitive within us that recognizes
truth it's part of our survival
mechanism and like like I said before
that is why it's so important that shows
like yours and people like you still
have these honest conversations even
when you've got big Pharma and the the
rigged media working against it it's
really crucial in fact it might be more
crucial than ever to to stay honest and
operate on fact regarding this issue I
mean people literally dying it's it's
hugely important it doesn't get much
bigger than this Savannah I'm going to
give you the last word but before I do I
wanted to mention that uh I believe it
was yesterday's show it might have been
on Wednesday we actually got our first
ever fact check from the United Nations
because I questioned climate change so
they put an official climate change fact
check under our live stream from the
United Nations and if the United Nations
thinks you're a bad guy to me you're
probably a good guy so I feel pretty
good about that Samantha just bring us
home on the basic idea of how do we
break through the nonsense fauci MSNBC
it's not going to stop but some people
will be fighting for truth and to me
that's why I keep playing so many clips
of DeSantis it's like he's doing the
best job at that at the moment
definitely well the way we break through
is by going to Alternative media sources
and uh did the UN fact check you because
you brought up Greta thundberg's tweet
that she uh deleted from five years ago
where she said that we were all going to
be dead by now that top climate
scientists were saying that if we don't
get climate change under control in five
years we were all going to be gone that
was five years ago by the way is that
why you got that fact check Dave uh
again too that's why people gravitate to
Alternative media to uh platforms like
Twitter because they know that they can
find the truth there they know that they
can uh you know look for alternative
voices that are actually going to have
the courage to tell them the truth have
the courage not to be paid off by big
Pharma by all of these corporations and
actually say hey we have a problem in
society let's go ahead and fix it and
let's fight for our constitutional
rights let's fight for our truth so I'm
happy that you have the audience that
you do they're all clearly free thinkers
and uh you know that's the best way we
break through also be a part of your
community go out and have hard
conversations with people and really try
to go and uh you know speak to your
fellow American maybe try to do what I
did with this UT student and just ask
those critical questions and have people
start thinking for themselves as to why
they think the way that they do
Savannah you know how to end this show
that was mwah chef's kiss thank you both
you both were absolutely spectacular I'd
love to have you guys back I'm going to
continue at reubenreport.locals.com
right now for subscribers only so if you
want to join us over there feel free you
guys have a great weekend we'll see
everybody else on Monday thanks where
the hell are we
[Music]
thank you
what are we doing
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]